okay let's solve leak code 33 search and
rotated sorted array
so we're basically given an array that
was originally sorted like this one but
it then it became rotated like this one
and by rotated they mean that they took
a certain pivot or index of the array
like right over here and then they cut
it in half and then swap through the
portions right so you can basically
think of this right-hand portion being
swapped over to the left side over here
right that's what happened as you can
see here right these two halves were put
in the opposites position and we're also
given a target value in this example
target zero and we want to check if our
array contains this value if it does we
return the index if it doesn't we return
negative one the most straightforward
way to approach this problem is
literally just check every single value
is this our target is this our target
and eventually we get here this is our
target and then we return the index for
now this is just too trivial of a
solution right the time complexity isn't
bad it's o of n but can we do better in
this problem they literally tell us to
find a solution and that's of log n so
obviously we can and basically anytime
you're looking for a solution that's log
N or better than linear almost every
time you're going to be looking for a
binary search type solution so since
this array was originally rotated can we
use that to our advantage to potentially
find a binary search type solution for
this problem let's try to analyze it and
see what we can find so given that the
original array was sorted if we wanted
to represent that as a graph we would
basically have a continuously increasing
line it might not necessarily be linear
but it would always be increasing right
and then we took some pivot like over
here and then swapped these halves
around right so let's draw what that
would look like so let's say the left
side was exclusively greater than the
right side because that's what it means
by rotating the array right
so I think this is a pretty good way to
visualize the problem to kind of
understand what it would look like and
you can use this to your advantage to
find potential patterns that can help us
find a binary search solution so with a
problem like this you really have to
break it down into discrete cases and
then use those cases to form a solution
so the most obvious thing is that there
are two portions of the array right
there's a left portion and a right
portion both independently are sorted
right so it's like we have two halves
that are sorted and so we know that a
binary search usually has three pointers
a left pointer a middle pointer and a
right pointer the left is always going
to be less than or equal to the right
this is just something you kind of know
from binary search so let's say our
middle value was six at some point right
this means that we're in the left sorted
portion of the array so can we use that
to our advantage so let's say our target
was greater than six in that case we
know for sure since we're in the left
sorted portion of the array none of
these values are greater than six so we
can basically say these are eliminated
let's run binary search on this portion
now right so that's pretty easy if we
know that we're in the left sorted
portion and our target is greater than
the middle this is what we can do
what if our target is less than the
middle value so what if our target was
less than six well these two numbers are
less than six and these three numbers
are less than six so how do we know
which way to go do we go left or do we
go right because we can't go both
directions in a binary search the key is
to see that in our left sorted portion
the smallest value is right here right
or on our graph it's right here
so if our target is even smaller than
this left value for in that case we know
that we don't have to search for we
don't have to search five we don't have
to search six week
binarysearch over here but if our value
is greater than or equal to four then
that means we're gonna run binary search
on this on these two values right it's
less than six but it's greater than or
equal to four so we can run binary
search on these two values we can
eliminate all of these from
consideration so all of that is if we
were in the left sorted portion of the
array right now what happens if we're in
the right sorted portion of the array
let's say our middle was one and let's
say we knew somehow that we were in the
right sorted portion of the array what
if our target was less than one well
then we know we have to search the left
the only value less than one is right
here so we're gonna search the left
portion of this array we're not gonna
look at one we're not gonna look at two
anymore any value to the right of one is
greater than one so we don't have to
look at them we're just gonna run binary
search on these elements we don't
necessarily have to know where the pivot
even is we just know we have to go left
but what if our target was greater than
one well then our solution could
possibly be two it could also be any of
these four values so then where do we go
again we can use this rightmost value or
the edge basically of our right to our
advantage
so if our target is greater than one and
it's also greater than two that means we
can again search this left portion we
can eliminate these two from
consideration but what if the opposite
is true
what if our target is greater than one
but it's less than or equal to two in
that case we only have to run binary
search on the right portion of one every
value to the right of one meaning we can
eliminate all of these from
consideration so that was a lot of
discrete cases and it might be confusing
I think it'll be a little easier to
understand once we actually write the
code but I think it's also
important to visualize it and actually
understand what's going on before you
even write a single line of code and
knowing what we just learned let's just
go through this example of the target
equal to zero and given this input array
so initially our left pointer would be
here our right pointer would be here our
middle would be here so how do we even
know if we're in the left sorted portion
or the right sorted portion
well the way I check is just if our
middle value is greater than or equal to
our left the actual value at that index
if this is true then that means our
middle value belongs to the left sorted
portion if this wasn't true that means
our middle values in the right sorted
portion and we would write our if
statements accordingly but knowing that
we are in this left sorted portion right
let's run through it so our target is
zero that means our target is less than
seven so our target is less than seven
that means we could be looking here or
we could be looking here so let's
compare it to four now is our target
less than the leftmost value well zero
is less than four okay so that means
we're all good we just have to search
every value to the right of our middle
value so we can eliminate all of these
we can cross out our middle and left our
new left is going to be here and our new
middle is going to be here now in this
case are we in the left sorted portion
or the right sorted portion well among
these three values the entire array is
pretty much sorted so according to our
thing according to our if statements
were basically going to say that middle
belongs to the left sorted portion
because the entire thing is sorted so
now we compare middle to target well our
target is less than one so now we have
to go left and if we compared it to the
leftmost value zero
our target is greater than or equal to
not so we don't have to check anywhere
else we only have to go left so we can
eliminate these two from consideration
and we're left with one value over here
and that's our solution so
this is kind of a visualization for it
now let's actually look at the code to
better understand what these cases are
going to look like okay so when you're
doing binary search first thing you do
is initialize your pointer so we have a
left and we have a right left is going
to be 0 right is going to be the length
of the array minus 1 our condition is
while left is less than or equal to
right because imagine we're given an
array like this with just one value
let's say it had one left and right
would be equal in that case and we still
have to check that one value so now we
can compute the middle value middle is
just going to be left + right / to the
average of them and it's possible to the
middle value could be the target if it
is we simply return the index if that's
not the case then we need to check which
portion of the array are we in are we in
the left sorted portion and like I
mentioned before we can check that if
the middle value is greater than the
left value well greater than or equal
right because it's possible that the
middle value in the left value could be
the same value the else condition would
be that we're in the right sorted
portion so the simplest case is that our
target is greater than the middle value
in that case we're going to search right
so we can say our left pointer is now
going to be mid plus 1 so if the target
is actually less than the middle then we
need to do something else so if the
target is less than the middle but it's
also less than the left most value in
nums then we also have to search the
right portion so we're gonna do left is
mid plus 1 now notice how these two
cases are evaluating to the same thing
that means we can condense them we can
get rid of this and say instead if the
top if target is greater than the middle
or
if the target is less than the left-most
value then we have to search the right
portion so we can get rid of this and if
this isn't true that means the target is
less than the middle but it's greater
than the left that means we search the
left portions so we can update our right
pointer
I had a typo over here we don't we're
not calling it left we're just calling
it L for short and so this is if we were
in the right sorted portion of the array
the easy thing is if target is less than
the middle that means we go left so we
can update our right pointer to mid
minus one so if this isn't true meaning
target is greater than middle and the
target is greater than the rightmost
value that means we have to go left as
well so write equals mid minus one
notice again how these two are doing the
exact same thing so we can condense them
we can say at the top if the target is
less than the middle or if target is
greater than the rightmost value then
we're going to search the left portion
so we update our right pointer so we get
rid of this and the else condition is
that the target is greater than the
middle value and the target is less than
the right value in that case we only
have to search the right portion of the
array so we update our left pointer to
mid plus one these are all of the cases
right so if we find our result we're
going to return it up here but if we
don't find it we'll exit the loop and
we'll return negative one and just as I
expected because I just finished this
problem like a half hour ago it worked
perfectly so this is not an easy problem
the code looks pretty easy but you
really have to understand the discrete
cases like are we in the left sorted
portion or the right sorted portion and
then what's going to happen as a result
which part of the array do we have to
check based on the
Harrison conditions you really want to
dry it out and kind of look at the
picture before you write the code I hope
this was helpful if it was leave a like
and subscribe and thank you for watching